Jamie starts us off this hour in
Montgomery Alabama hi Jamie welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show thank you okay no I
have to talk to you you too how can I
help okay we have had bedbugs for three
years now almost you've had one bed bugs
bed bugs done done done yeah we've
already paid for two professional
treatments averaging $1,500 each and
they have both failed we have confirmed
now that they are inside the walls and
despite tons of things that we've done
to kill them they are not dying we now
have a crossroads we can either tear out
all of our drywall and siding as close
to simultaneously as possible spray
inside the walls and put all that back
up which makes no sense because where
are your water on this mortgage we've
bought this house before the market
crashed about six months and the Matt
the house is totaled so our other option
is to take out a another mortgage and
meticulously move treat this house empty
which is the only way the exterminator
said would kill them and then rent this
place off
meticulously move we may just move your
stuff I mean we would have to do most of
our things behind anything that we would
be able to take we would have to put in
the dryer I've already decided we each
get like two outfits and yeah we would
have to leave all of our furniture all
of our bedding it would basically be
like starting over completely isn't if
our house burned down except we have to
burn down ourselves so I know the
furniture and the clothing and so forth
by and large everything just goes in the
dumpster
pretty much and the noise then you just
be my gate the house yeah we have four
kids and and how long does it take to
fumigate the house Oh
that will be a process the exterminators
I don't want to talk bad about people on
your radio show but let's just say we
would be treating ourselves because we
care and we've learned so much that we
know how to treat it if it's empty but
with four kids
square feet there's no it is control the
movement of hugs and the exterminators
told us that they basically walked in
and said yeah okay I mean we'll give it
a shot but this probably isn't gonna
work and they were right but of course
we had no choice really but to try so we
would have to empty this house I got
that part
how long does it take you to treat the
house oh sorry
probably about six months because of the
way that bedbugs reproduce in the way
they lay eggs and how long it takes to
hatch and move on they eat their dead so
not being here doesn't stop them from
reproducing so we just have to we'll
have to come at probably twice a month
for six months and we would still be
praying we got them all um you know more
a lot more about this than I do and
you've lived a nightmare obviously I
don't know anything about this I've
never faced this particular thing with
insects it sounds like I mean i-i've got
to be looking for some more reasonable
way to treat this situation then a six
month empty house and six months of rent
and what is your household income we
just now make 40,000 a year mm-hmm yeah
and what is the house worth the house is
worth twenty thousand less than we paid
for it what is the house worth
sorry fifty three right now fifty three
thousand that's with bedbugs with
bedbugs we can put a little Roman we owe
64 okay all right and what will it cost
to treat it probably about a thousand
dollars over the six months which is
very reasonable and the second mortgage
would be for furniture no we were
we're going to have we're probably going
to have to outright buy another house
and there's a foreclosure in the market
rent another house but no one wants to
rent to us because we have bugs and
we're not taking the bugs with you
Lord willing okay now you're being
dramatic you just told me you're leaving
with two pairs of clothing or no
clothing and leaving everything else
behind in a dumpster unless they're in
your ears you're not taking the bugs
with you okay that that's that's how
purply at this stage so you know what I
would do I would just shovel everything
out of the house and throw it away and
sell the house and start again we would
be selling bed books to people tell them
they're there we'll have to sell the
house for fifty three thousand dollars
and walk away I don't think you know
give it you know this is too just too
much crap for a tiny little house this
is not that big a deal I mean you're
yeah this is absolutely consumed your
life I'm walking away I'm gonna start my
life again I'm gonna walk away but no
one will buy it it's more trying our
neighborhood has gone downhill it
experienced a little around the market
with a realtor in short sell the house I
would not keep the house I would not do
the plan you're doing it is just too
all-consuming it's not worth it
I they win I surrender you bugs can have
it and you know you've just you've just
described to me a completely untenable
life in an untenable situation and so we
have to do something if it is as
dramatic as you have described the only
thing the only only positive answer to
the situation is a dramatic answer start
over throw everything away don't keep
anything and go start over it's cheaper
it's cheaper to do that and just go rent
something and start to buy you some
clothing and buy you some used furniture
and just start your life again just
start fresh and then once you get some
furniture and some stuff you get
yourself out of debt once you're out of
that you build your emergency fund once
you have your emergency fund you save
with a down payment you buy another
house but no I just there's no way I'm
going to all this crap it's not like
this is a house that's worth fighting
for it's just a stupid house
in the distant the game it's a really
stupid house you know there's no way I
would just sell it get your realtor put
it up for short sale but house has bugs
it's cheap you know we're gonna make you
a deal on it and you know work with a
mortgage company work out a short sale
and walk away I'm walking away from this
thing and let somebody else some
investor we can deal with this you know
they'll sell so they'll FEMA gate it let
it sit there six months or whatever they
got to do to get it right and then
they'll put it on the market rent it
somebody'll work it out but you're
you're done kiddo this thing's eating
you alive no pun intended I mean this is
this is crazy so that's what I would do
you ask what I do I add it and worth it
it isn't worth it it is not worth it
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]